an independent journalist named Taylor
Hansen reports on
and we've seen a lot of these
unfortunately
but this one
this one still somehow shocked me this
is a an all ages drag show another one
this is in Austin Texas it's a Christmas
themed drag show a show that's
apparently touring through 18 different
states 36 different shows this month
um and I can't even show you most of the
videos and images he posted
yeah I mean suffice it to say that they
are just blatantly sexual even more so
than some of the other footage that
we've seen no mistake we're talking
about barely clothed performers
simulating sex acts on each other on
stage talking graphically about sex
um
a explicitly sexual performance with
kids in the audience kids who are
invited because this was advertised as
an all-ages Direction
so here's actually we'll play One Clip
this is one of the Tamer Clips this is
one of the clips that we that I can play
and even this it has to be bleeped and
censored and all the rest of it and
remember there are young children in the
in the audience and this deviant
scumbag who you're going to see here is
actually at one point talking to a young
child in the audience uh anyway here it
is
oh wow oh I'm feeling Moody tonight I'm
so happy to be here thank you also for
coming out oh my God so many of you oh
I'm so excited hello are you reaching
for my birthday hungry
[Applause]
trust me the milk's gone bad you don't
want this bro I know when I've been on
tour we've been on the tour bus I've
been unrefrigerated thank you so much
for this donation
I'm gonna put this to good use I'm gonna
buy more breasts and more now I brought
for you some of my best breasts I
brought for you my grandmother's breasts
yes hand it down to me generation to
generation oh my God hello gray sexy
beautiful nice to see you I had the best
time today with gray and Weston in the
glass coffins
well if you have it you go check it out
they asked me do you want to see the
haunted section I was like hello do I
want to see the haunted section I feel
like I have a haunted section I said
let's go
no but I've been having the best time
turning around I've been working so hard
I've actually worked my butthole right
off look at that
gone
it's a don't cry sir don't cry oh my
eyes
okay so he uh
yes he did show off his bare butt to the
audience there when he said that and uh
and earlier in the clip was talking to a
child
saying are you hungry in reference to
his fake breasts that he was shown off
there
uh
I I'm at a point now I'm almost like a
single issue voter on this it's not the
only issue but it's the litmus test it's
a perfect litmus test
and I'm not I I
don't want to vote for anyone who get
into 2024
I'm not going to vote for you unless you
promised me that
like that sort of scene
that you're going to be sending federal
agents into there
to arrest every adult
in attendance every adult in attendance
and every adult on stage
okay I want I want I want law
enforcement agents running up onto that
stage
tackling that piece of garbage that scum
dragging him off the stage by his feet
while he's in handcuffs that's what I
want
I'll vote for any presidential candidate
who promises that
what you need to understand here is that
we are dealing with with
pure evil this is pure evil the people
who are doing this
are evil
the people that are that are attending
it
and the people who support it
everything I know people don't you don't
want to think this way about your fellow
Americans especially if you go online
you see the number of of just seemingly
normal Americans who will defend this
and you think I can't believe that there
are so many evil people in this country
there are
and they are evil people
who we should
not want to compromise with not want to
reach an understanding
I don't want to be nice and polite with
you and
I'm not going to say well we disagree on
these issues but we could still be nice
to each other I don't want to be nice to
you
I don't want to be around you
I want nothing to do with you I don't
want to share a country with you I don't
want to share a planet with you that's
how much I despise everything you
represent
so with this this is not compromise okay
all we can do with this is crush it
destroy it
that's what you do with evil
and that's what we have to do with this
that should be our objective
because this is very plainly
the mass sexual abuse of kids
happening in plain sight
and they're not sorry and they're not
ashamed and they're not ever going to
stop until they're made to stop
by the way glad uh tweeted this a couple
days ago
drag phobia is on the rise there's clear
and present danger against our community
and threats I really haven't seen it at
this level in over a decade if ever
that's quoting a drag queen
there's people are angry at our
community
well yeah you're you're sexually
grooming children in front of everyone
people tend to get mad about that that's
right
I can't believe this
I can't believe it
we can't prance around uh on stage half
naked in front of kids without people
getting upset
you know it as I've been saying all
along
you could J here's an idea to the quote
drag queen community
it's not a real community
the fact the fact that you all have a
thing for wearing women's clothes that
doesn't make you a community it's not a
community
um but here's an idea
if you don't like the reaction you're
getting from the public maybe just stop
doing that how's that for an idea stop
doing it
none of this backlash is happening none
of this uh uh
scrutiny is being directed at you guys
if you aren't doing this
keep the kids out of it you perverts
keep them out of it and there's no
problem
nobody was talking about drag drags
existed for a long time no one was
talking about it until you start
involving kids and that's when it became
an issue have you noticed the connection
keep the kids out of it
and no one cares
you want to go to your gay clubs or
whatever and do your uh your your drag
your your dumb drag shows with just a
bunch of adults
no I don't want to see it no one wants
to talk about it nobody cares
you bring kids into it and now it's a
problem
stop doing that and it's not a problem
anymore
so I mean just think about this
if it's true
that they're in fear for their lives and
they're getting all these threats and
everything and most of this is just
invented and made up
and even if it's true and and so
according to you you're getting threats
and all that because of uh you're
exposing kids to drag and you're still
doing it
so what like it's this important you're
going to risk your life
to expose children to drag that's how
important it is to you
to use the phrase It's always her like
me this is the hill you're gonna die on
foreign just makes me all the more
determined to oppose you
drag phobia they say
um
first of all it's not phobia
it's uh drag I don't know drag disgust
drag nausea one of those words not a
phobia
you don't scare me
I'm scared on behalf of the kids I'm
scared for the kids that are being
exposed to this stuff
and the effect it's going to have on
them
but no no no no one's afraid of you know
you don't scare anybody
a bunch of men in women's clothes
dancing around the stage you think that
you think that scares us
they try to have a belt both ways I
still terrified these people are they're
being so mean to us and they're afraid
of us which is it
but drag phobia so now that we have the
phobia attached to it uh that is now
confirmation that the the
metaphomorphosis is complete and now
drag queen has become its own identity
okay that's this is this is the final
step in uh in in inducting a you know
bringing a new identity into the fold
baptizing christening a new identity the
final step is to give it to give it its
own phobia
and as soon as that happens now drag
queens are their own ID I guarantee you
and this is I'm not saying this is a
joke it in very short order they're
going to add D for drag queen to the
LGBT alphabet soup it's going to be in
there they're going to get their own
they're gonna get their own stripe on
the uh on the increasingly cluttered
pride flag all that's being added in as
its own thing its own identity
now we knew that was happening too
because you see how even you know media
articles to talk about the drag queens
they always refer to the drag queens
with if you notice with the female
pronouns as if they actually are I mean
they are men performing as women
and yet
it's when we talk about them we're
supposed to talk about them as if their
characters are real and they really are
women
that's because it's finally changed over
now and drag queen is an identity and
the reason why they're making the shift
is that once they call something an
identity then you can't criticize it now
if it's just a hobby if it's just a
fetish if it's just a recreation if it's
just something like this then you can
criticize that all day long it was just
a profession you know you can criticize
that but identities you can't criticize
and so how do they take something take a
fetish take something and put it make it
above criticism just say that it's
identity
unfortunately I don't play along with
those rules I don't care if you call it
Identity or not
I'm still going to criticize it
that'll do it for this portion of the
shows move over to the members blog hope
to see you there if not talk to you on
Monday Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]